Oh John it's Tuesday January night I'm a
Detroit Michigan it's very windy and
cold I'm standing in the only place in
the continental United States where you
can look south and see Canada which you
are doing right now I'm also standing in
front of General Motors headquarters
it's a very very big building it's
really nice of you to say that I live in
a way that is commensurate with my
values
having feel my way lately
for the new year I drove to Spokane and
I flew to Reno and then I drove to Lake
Tahoe and then I did that all in Reverse
we're like a three-day long party and
now like a week later I've accepted an
invitation from General Motors
the North American International Auto
Show in Detroit Michigan I was invited
is because I read for a few
environmental laws and there's some
environmental things going on
those are my values this is not my
values it's kind of difficult to convey
what's really going on here it's a
pretty gigantic spectacle
looked earlier there's fake lichen on
those big rocks I'm here fake fire
and even know how that do
right in here
have the weirdest prettiest fake
waterfall ever and it spells things
right here we have a jeep that has
gotten stuck to the wall and all people
in that Jeep have had to jump out of the
Jeep
because they were stuck in a wall
General Motors is giving away hot dogs
- a long line
so lame
oh my god
every time
yeah
as for the Brotherhood 2.0 book club I'm
really excited that you're giving me
opportunities to read so many books
about genocide I love genocide in terms
of what you're going to read apparently
none of our viewers want you to read
anything because they all want you to
write so you should just go ahead and
read whatever it is you're writing I'm
going to make that your one option you
have to read the book you are writing
and that's for what to call it you're
gonna have to give me some time also
it'd be nice to know what it was about
I'd also like to say happy birthday to
Jesslyn shields a brotherhood 2.0 viewer
and one of my best friends